we are we are joined on a news now by uh
paula francis a longtime anchor here
kls hall of famer and a dear friend to
all of us and paula as you and i are
just talking off there i want to extend
my condolences to you and in the loss of
gary uh he was such a great friend to
you uh as well as a colleague for
you know we're talking three decades
and uh
the news so shocking to to everyone i'm
wondering uh not just the news anchor
gary but some of the the personal
recollections you have when you think
about the wonderful man he
was what did you think about today as
you reflected on gary
oh
you know brian i actually think about
gary every day um we were in touch quite
a lot um we shared a very similar sense
of humor um
people
always realized gary was just the
newsman that was his reputation and he
owned it and he was he really cared he
had the greatest bs detector of any new
person
but um
if you knew him in person he
he was the greatest kindest friend
anyone could have and he would do
anything for a friend he was just very
um there was no he was never stuck up or
or taken by his fame and he was really
famous you know you walk through a a
casino before a live shot or down the
strip or anywhere in town and people
would just stare at gary
he was he was famous but uh i was so
lucky to have him as a friend i was so
lucky to have him as a colleague the
years that i sat on the desk with gary
were the best years of my career
i remember a couple lunches with him i
was thinking it was like santa claus to
the north pole i didn't know if you're
gonna be able to get to order
everybody knew gary
one thing paula as you well know he was
so present in the newsroom with everyone
stopping at people's desks and really
lending time and getting to know
everyone
uh the interpersonal nature of him is
such a fond memory talk about that style
he had where he was uh leading up the
news team and and these newscasts but he
just had time for everyone seemingly all
the time
he did um he worked very hard because
you know he all he wrote all his scripts
or at least rewrote them in his style
which gave him that great every man kind
of delivery but in the newsroom he was a
great mentor and he would help out
anybody who whether they asked for it or
whether they needed it and didn't know
it and he had such great advice i think
about his advice every day sometimes
personal advice or things about the
world he was so in tune to
current events
to news to history and he really wanted
to impart that to young people i don't
know if you knew that his mom was a
teacher and so
gary was kind of a teacher that way
i wasn't that much younger than him but
he taught me a lot some of the best
lessons that i i could learn in
journalism and how how to relate to the
viewer and how to think about our
responsibility as well as staying humble
can you share a piece of advice or maybe
something a motto of his that he
imparted over the years
yes you know um
newsrooms are are
full of a range of people and a lot of
times um the
the industry gets gets sort of a
reputation for choosing people who are
you know good looking or they could have
been a model but they wound up here you
know whatever that song is
gary always said
find the smartest people you can and
hire them and teach them tv
it was his belief that a smart person
could learn the job and would be better
at someone who just looked the part
well put
commercial breaks during a newscast
often a time of great banter joking
around sometimes relatively blue humor
talk about what gary was like
in between the newscast and during the
commercial breaks
we talked from the moment the
microphones went off to the moment they
came back on we were so involved as
friends and we were involved in the news
and talking about what was going on but
gary was a great joke teller and he
could really tell jokes well fortunately
for him i couldn't remember jokes
we went through like 20 years sitting
together on the set and he could tell me
a joke over and over and over again and
i would still laugh hysterically
he did appreciate that um
but uh one of the things about gary you
know sometimes brian i'm sure you've had
the occasion when something strikes you
funny and it's not appropriate and
all of a sudden you find yourself trying
to stifle the laughter yes well gary and
i had a few moments like that and i i
won't tell you what the context was
because no one would want to know that
but gary had this huge grin and these
beautiful teeth and you didn't see him
really smile or laugh that much unless
he was really really broken up and when
i saw his teeth and that big smile and
then his eyes would kind of scrunch up
and then i was helpless you know i
couldn't talk he couldn't talk so they
just had to go to commercial it's
contagious you just lose it you start
biting the inside of your cheeks
anything to try to stop it
yep
you as a team gary uh gary and paula as
a team covered some of the biggest
stories in las vegas history uh you were
there together uh navigating uh
everything from pepcon uh to mgm to some
of the biggest in the in the history of
our city what was it like to to anchor
and drive a newscast
with gary you guys were such a
tremendous team what was that like in
terms of the news and journalistic
portion of it
harry knew
so much and he had
a mind like a steel trap for details and
facts and he could just pull them out of
thin air so it was really a great
blessing to sit next to an anchor like
that who could really carry it and and
he knew
so much about las vegas and he really it
was like he was woven into
the fabric of las vegas so he could talk
on anything to do with las vegas
breaking news became less and less
common you know i don't know why that is
but we used to go on at the drop of a
hat and go in what we called
wall-to-wall news
on 9 11
gary and i came in
and there was nothing to do on channel 8
because cbs took over
and so gary and i went on las vegas one
which was the cable station that we had
at that time and we had no information
but we just kept talking and talking to
each other and talking about what it
meant and we had wire services in those
days
of course cell phones and and all of
that good stuff that we rely on now but
uh
gary could always bring not just
background and history but he brought
perspective
he knew where things fit
in the great fabric of mankind he he
just had a sense for it
how about the more unique aspects of
gary when you think about working in the
newsroom with him i i think about the
the tarantula frankie
yes maybe the newsroom mascot is what we
could call frankie or i mean every i
don't know how many times he told me you
got to go see the big horn sheep in
boulder city and talk a lot talk about
some of the unique personality traits
that made gary so lovable
that's lovable um
yeah he uh he loved the nevada desert he
loved his motorcycle um he was always
out there with his friends you know and
he had all the equipment and he had one
of those stereos
and he could talk to the other guys on
his on his bike and he loved that but he
also had the gentle side where he loved
that tarantula frankie and you know he'd
pull the he pulled frankie out when uh
we'd have a tour of uh boy scouts or
girl scouts or students had come through
the newsroom and pretty soon they'd all
be gathered around his desk and he'd
have the spider out you know and people
would want to hold it and it really made
it kind of cute
there were always people that were
seemingly drawn to frankie and then
people that were running the other way
yes that's true and gary often
encouraged me to hold on to frankie put
him in my hand but i couldn't because i
thought well if if frankie moves you
know or starts up my arm then i'm going
to toss him against the wall and gary
will be really upset and i couldn't
stand that
i could talk to you all day new year's
eve you guys did so many fantastic shows
together it was a staple of las vegas uh
to to watch the two of you bring in the
new year
that's such a fun night it's such a
party it's joyful
what are some of your memories of uh
anchoring and taking home that new
year's eve newscast with gary
oh
we loved it you know
las vegas is such a special place and on
new year's eve it just pulls out all the
stops and to be right in the middle of
it on the strip we just loved it it did
have kind of a scary element because the
crowds were very big yes um but we
always had a good time and we we felt so
special because every new casino that
opened we knew we would be doing new
year's eve there
and it was just great gary again you
know it was just great to be beside him
on a news set or out in the world doing
whatever he was
he always knew what he was talking about
he always kept it together and i would
always kind of lose it on new year's eve
but
he kept me down to earth so we were a
great team and we had a great time you
were a great team i was looking at a
picture of you and gary dave and a
couple others from the 65th anniversary
celebration a couple years ago what was
that like to to reunite with the squad
it must have been special
it's like that no time passes at all you
know every time i saw gary after he
retired in 2012 um it was it was just
you know there was no in between time
and i saw him um at a going away party
for one of our channel eight
colleagues just this spring and we were
all excited because we'd been vaccinated
and we felt free we were at a party for
the first time and he was just in his
element it was so great to see him he
enjoyed life he really did i'm telling
some of our younger colleagues about
gary and i'm curious how would you
describe gary in a couple of words
someone that was such a close friend and
colleague of yours for so long
solid news man
greatest friend
beautifully said
paula it's been a joy talking to you i i
i don't know what's in the water in
wisconsin but you're ageless and and you
look fantastic and and we so appreciate
you taking the time and sharing some of
your memories of a wonderful man
thank you for giving me the chance to
talk about gary all right thanks paula
appreciate it